so in an objective sense, this was an absolutely
disastrous weekend for Donald Trump, but I
want to try to think about it from the perspective
of the average Trumpist because the left recognizing
that Donald Trump has failed again, doesn't
really do much for us.
We're already not voting for the guy in November
of 2020 so let's review number one.
Donald Trump has had to abandon pushing a
question about citizenship into the 2020 census.
The pressure became too great.
The risk of delaying the census altogether
grew too large at courts.
We're deciding against Donald Trump.
So Trump has bailed out by saying, you know
what, we're not going to keep going with the
citizenship question on the census.
But he tried to kind of save face by saying,
well, we can get the citizenship information
from existing federal records.
Of course.
Why not just plan to do that from the beginning
if it's so easy to get that information from
records that already exist, but a definitive
and total failure by Donald Trump.
Another failure over the weekend is that Donald
Trump's labor secretary has been forced to
resign over his involvement and what was arguably
a, um, uh, a moral and potentially criminal
involvement in a plea deal for accused sex
trafficker and rapists and Trump friend Jeffrey
Epstein.
Now, I'm not actually saying that Alexander
Acosta, Trump's now resigned or soon a labor
secretary, uh, is going to be convicted of
any crime for his involvement in that plea
deal.
That's not how it works.
There's immunity for prosecutors who participate
in this way, but there is a case to be made
that what took place violates multiple principles
of how the justice system is supposed to operate
by law.
Uh, what took place is that Alexander Acosta
back when in Florida, he was handling Jeffrey
Epstein's, uh, sex crimes case struck a just
ridiculous plea deal in 2008.
Uh, and the pressure also started to mount
and Acosta is leaving, which ups the number
of currently acting cabinet secretaries to
four, which is just absolutely ridiculous.
The inability to fill important positions
by the Trump administration is, uh, really
an internal crisis that is not being covered
nearly the, to the extent that it should.
So by any objective measure, terrible weekend
losing another cabinet secretary, the controversy
around Jeffrey Epstein, it continues to inch
closer and closer to Donald Trump himself.
Remember that Trump is accused of raping the
same 13 year old girl that accused Jeffrey
Epstein as well.
And he gives up one of his big red meat nationalist
ideas of the citizenship question on the census.
But we all know that this is another failure,
another set of failures by Donald Trump.
We already weren't voting for him.
So what we really need to do is dive into
how the average Trump is going to see this.
And this is really important.
Okay.
The failure on some parts of the left to think
about the Trump campaign as a right winger
would see it back in 2016 was a big blind
spot.
And we don't want to do this again.
In 2020 a Trumpist is going to see Trump's
failure to get the citizens ship question
into the census as Trump just being held down
by liberal activist judges.
And they will say, see, we told you this proves
that nobody other than Trump cares about immigration.
Trump wants to keep us safe.
He's great, and all of these liberal activist
judges are preventing Donald Trump from securing
the United States from immigrants a Trumpist.
We'll see the labor secretary resignation
once again as that oppressive, regressive
leftist mob that's bullying people and is
intolerant and is forcing them out just to
hurt Donald Trump.
Now, what I've just told you is laughable
too, a clear thinking person, but the Trumpist
will see it and will be emboldened by this.
So these things aren't going to move the needle
in the battle to remove Donald Trump in the
next election.
Now.
Also, just a funny and bizarre moment, Donald
Trump in a public statement that he made defending
Alexandra Costa just says, Alexander Acosta
is Hispanic.
Like as part of the defense, basically saying,
Hey, I had a Hispanic guy.
How great is that?
Take a look at this.
Alex called me this morning and he wanted
to see me and I actually said, well, we have
the press right out here, so perhaps you just
want to say it to the breasts, but I just
want to let you know this was him, not me,
because I'm with them.
He was a tremendous talent.
He's a Hispanic man.
He went to Harvard, a great student.
I didn't want him to resign.
He's smart and he's Hispanic, but the most
telling thing is that Donald Trump feels bad
for Acosta.
Okay?
Acosta participated in brokering a disgusting
plea deal.
A normal person would see the situation and
they would say, wow, I feel really bad for
Epstein's victims who saw Epstein get a ridiculously
lacked deal of, I think it was 13 months,
and I don't know exactly how much would that
he ultimately serve.
And instead Trump feels bad for the attorney
who had the gall to strike such a ridiculous
and immoral plea deal with a predator.
The likes of Jeffrey Epstein.
These are really dark times.
Everything is backwards.
But if we ignore it, if we just say, Hey,
I'm a leftist, here are my values.
Here's how I react to what Donald Trump is
doing.
We're missing the boat.
That's not going to help us win in 2020 and
we need to win.
I want to win.
So we've got to be thinking about these things
in terms of how will a Trumpist see and interpret
them.
And I'm going to continue trying to do that
as we get closer and closer to the 2020 election.